yeah welcome to this video playing um I
think it's Nicole I shall die f from
Russia pretty high rated 27 something
and let's play a 3 transpose to a sort
of Z mesh variation but it's it's a bit
bit of the same as with the twist he
doesn't need to play Knight f6 he can
play 97 this is the that DM of the slide
one of the ideas hmm maybe it is an idea
for me to go to g three with a night
quickly one ideas if I go night dear
Bishop d3 that is going to play Bishop
f5 so maybe it is an idea to sort of
from prophylactically moved the night
here and kaveh f5 so I'm preparing
Bishop d3 this line was Bishop before
it's actually quite interesting I am had
thought about employing this a while ago
at the end I I decided against that I
think but I'm not quite sure how why
what the exact Therese was okay
interesting is there should I think
about a for Bishop e3 activating it in
this way or f 34 f 3 f is always got f
52 to block it not not entirely sure
i'm not sure i'm not very familiar with
this supposition type it is some as
mentioned similar to the sameish but
this night only seven is really am
changing a lot of the sunda structure i
was thinking about taking actually or
maybe I may be here this is not bad he
cannot go a six now at the moment
maybe I can let's let's do this first I
don't really have a clear plan I admit
that I've thinking maybe queen a6 take
on c5 rook be five or first here and get
this idea to play to take and play will
be five maybe this is maybe this is
completely naive but I have a hard time
finding a plan yeah if i take now it's
not great yeah maybe i should anyway or
is this no I was thinking about if I
have briefly anyway if I take and
playbook b5 attacking come on I need to
be quick i am of course you can do that
but it's this how terrible is this is so
bad i have a7 as some as a target and
yeah okay you can do that night i can i
can use the night as well
night hmm I don't know and need I need
some security thumb back rank impossible
to do it without night a fiver thought
to just route b5 and take a seven if it
takes c3 g4 is not such a bad square
night before Scott yeah but what if I
just draw back I can just drop back here
I am that's not so great here yeah maybe
Queen cheer for it's an additional idea
you know this is a tough tough defense I
just have the weaker bones on c3 and a
foreign that c4 was also strong at least
i have ninety-seven throat and if you
fall maybe yeah what hmm really the SWAT
the best i don't believe that
maybe it's it's still greater but I
thought I really wasn't much in much
more trouble um just take it all can
also go here the rook a4 is a bit
outside at the moment
hmm
I'm not sure it is just great for white
I'm difficult so very much a technical
matter but with enough time on my hand I
I don't know I am I think it looks very
very tricky for black now now Kenneth
minish with this with this time deficit
now I gave up the pawn
check
check check but even this position is
completely clear yeah yeah but what what
about this position what is mating yeah
it's checkmate I had lots of activity
still at the end right to the end okay
it's not objectively great but um and
this is this is made even I came yeah I
spoil this I was white was certainly
winning about him how much is it five
point six points it had just three
probably there were there were more 66
is alright night before of course here
not before yeah not sharp enough
technically this is just curtains just
promote actually yeah and resins I was
worth before but he I think he'd simply
he simply blundered to this 97 stuff no
it said certainly a quite okay and and
round he is starting to to risk too much
not quite sure but down okay here we can
take only five but he probably thought
was not enough and this is just playing
for loss really yeah complicated game
but this is an interesting opening
something to do to look at a few look
for this stuff if you look for an
interesting way to play in the Queens
gambit thanks for watching